[Música]
y en directo a nos quedamos aquí en
américa latina' con la noticia que
conmociona a la política sudamericana
ese atentado fallido contra la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- natalio
cosoi quien ha estado haciendo
seguimientos sobre el terreno de las
manifestaciones que marcaron la jornada
de hoy en rechazo al ataque contra
fernández a natalio cómo transcurrió
esta fecha y qué se sabe sobre la
investigación
hola que tal buenas noches fue una forma
de una gran movilización ahora me
encuentro junto a la puerta del
domicilio de cristina fernández de
kirchner de ella no está aquí y salió
más temprano pero todavía quedan algunas
pocas personas aquí la movilización más
grande fue a la plaza de mayo frente a
la casa de gobierno sí fue realmente
masiva una movilización muy muy grande
en apoyo a la vicepresidente y en
rechazo a este ataque fallido que sufrió
el día jueves respecto a las
investigaciones avanzan las
investigaciones de la justicia se fueron
tomando a la jueza y el fiscal fueron
tomando declaraciones a lo largo del día
a varios de los testigos incluso se
trasladaron hasta aquí hasta este lugar
y aquí hablaron con la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández según medios locales
ella dijo que en el momento del disparo
que es algo que hemos visto mucho y
repetidas veces ella no se dio cuenta de
lo que ocurría algo parecía verse en
imagen y otro dato importante que
también están dando medios locales es
que la jueza fiscal fueron a tomar
declaración al hombre que intentó es que
gatilló ese arma intentó disparar
contra la vicepresidenta y él decidió no
dar ninguna declaración hasta ahora
diríamos que son los detalles más
salientes de la investigación hasta el
momento siempre esperando que se sepa
cuál pudo haber sido el motivo de este
ataque y si fue algo que hizo por su
cuenta si estuvo ayudado por alguien más
y forma parte de una organización o no
que son cosas que todavía no tienen
respuesta una tarea de argentina
atraviesa un momento particular de
polarización y crispación social y en
este contexto resurgió un debate y
ciertos planteos sobre los discursos de
odio que pueden motivar este tipo de
actos que nos puede decir usted al
respecto
bueno desde el gobierno salieron
fuertemente a decir que un contexto de
discursos de odio ha sido si se quiere
lo que permitió que surgiera una
situación como la del día jueves y
salieron a pedir que se corte con los
discursos de odio que se empiece a
encontrar consensos hubo una reunión por
ejemplo hoy el presidente alberto
fernández con ciertos sectores de
sindicatos religiosos empresarios para
de organizaciones de derechos humanos
también para hablar al respecto sacaron
un comunicado pero por ejemplo no
participaron de esas reuniones en los
políticos de la oposición la oposición
al gobierno y es ahí donde empieza a
haber algo de ruido hay que ver si ellos
la oposición que para algunos en el
gobierno encarnan en algunos casos estos
discursos de odio y el gobierno pueden
empezar a acercarse y dialogar para
romper con esta lógica
[Música]